hi everyone so last year I made a video
about India's JEA advanced exam but I
don't think that I really did it justice
so for this video I wanted to invite
some experts and science and engineering
to share their thoughts on the exam they
spoke about the difficulty of the
questions whether they thought the exam
would prepare students well for the
future and also shared their thoughts on
exams as a whole I also spoke to a
couple of Indian students who took the
je and are now doing research work here
in Australia for those not familiar the
je e exam is an admissions exam and two
engineering colleges and it's set by
over a million students competing for
just a few thousand places you set two
papers each three hours long on the same
day and it's a little multi choice so
with that let's hear what people had to
say about it I think this is a it's it's
it's a very tough exam so if I was a
student at high school and if this was
intimidating when you first read it I
would not be surprised and if it's not
at all intimidating for you then I would
say congratulations because well it's
really really interesting
it looks pretty difficult for example
the question in physics I know I
couldn't probably can't answer you know
maybe most of it now though maybe 30
years back I could do you know these
these exams seem you know they're very
long they have a very wide variety of
questions they cover and they're they're
hard I think any student who comes up
against these exams it's gotta feel
pretty lousy by the end of it I'd
probably you know leave the exam room
crying if I wasn't in year 12 I had to
Davis yeah good luck good luck
[Music]
so when we compare this jhm with some of
the subjects that are taught here in
some of our uno cities in Australia so
here is a question paper I was looking
at the depth of question that are asked
can be one difficult for students in the
first or second year who are studying in
bachelor degree level in Australia
it's really quite ambitious with that
trying to test chemistry and physics and
maths and the paper is light up fairly
nicely in that you have to earn one mark
per minute looking at the questions a
lot of them are in some sense sort of
elementary in the sense that they use
the kind of maths
taught in high schools although in some
areas I would say the syllabus in
calculus and a couple of other areas
goes somewhat beyond what is currently
taught in Australian schools are
currently examined in Australian schools
but a lot of the questions are basically
tricky or slightly sneaky but also don't
necessarily require you to work through
the question in full detail it with
multiple choice questions you or you
have to simply decide can I reject this
possibility or not there is some attempt
to stop people gaming that way by
applying penalties to some wrong it but
to some wrong answers but still it's
very much a race against the clock
I think the mathematic questions are
clever it looks for the person's
understanding of the matter just rather
than doing some direct questions so in
that sense I am you know they are there
okay they can they can be done and you
know some of these concepts I do even
use in my course here in masters course
here especially those involves with the
system of linear equations and
determinants and those concepts so
concepts like high spin and low spin
you know get at complexes that's
something that the University of
Melbourne in firstly chemistry we would
treat in second semester there was a
question on essentially Iranian equation
so rates of a rate of reaction as a
function of a free energy of the keeps
free energy so here we go it ask you
something like the activation energy the
backward reaction
exceeds that of the forward reaction by
two R T so again you've got it basically
I think you'd have to you have to sketch
this out you'd have to think about okay
if if the back reaction is exceeding the
forward reaction what's the what's the
reaction free energy um so it's not just
the concepts are difficult i think it's
asking you in a way that is that is
tricky you have to think about you it's
not just enough to know the equation and
you know throwing the numbers you've got
to think about it before you get the
number that you're throwing into the
equation and obviously that and they're
not letting you have a calculator so
[Music]
definitely this will set up basic by now
like a background in a baseline so you
could imagine that all the IT students
would have come with they would have had
firmed up the fundamentals but from then
onwards there are so many things to
learn because after you come to the IITs
there is still you know only it will be
like a bell curve again you know for
example you give a given exam exam to
you know very tough exam and choose the
best in the world and then give them
them another exam and still again the
performance is going to be like a bell
but this happened to be this is kind of
something that is there it's kind of
basic needed basic foundations for
engineering but I would guess or nearly
the majority of them would be ready to
do for you know go for especially
engineer occasion and that that explains
why for example IIT students are you
know IIT graduates are doing well around
the world I had a look at a couple of
the one-hour math sections of papers and
I would say I would be fairly challenged
to get a decent resolve on those
in an hour partly because as a
professional mathematician I'm
interested in actually telling a story
when I answer a problem I want to lay
out why the answer I'm producing is the
answer simply being available the answer
is 27 to me is not so helpful also
interesting and in terms of future
success in in mathematics or indeed in
many scientific disciplines the ability
to reason properly and to explain your
reasoning clearly is terribly terribly
important so while I have no reason to
believe that using the exam the way it's
used isn't selecting very bright
students for the engineering colleges
that they're going to it's not clear to
me that it's the optimal selector of
that and there is also the ugly question
of coaching and unequal access to
resources we all know that in any
educational system if you go to a good
school well resourced with the best
teachers and so on like that you expect
a better outcome that's ultimately the
main justification for spending money on
education as a society that if you work
harder at it you produce better results
but with these race against the clock
style examinations there's a trade-off
between the student's ability in the
subject natural intelligent other things
like that
and there having been trained to do
about examinations of this type exams
can have different purpose and entry
exams that are sort of in a form of a
drill type of questions usually require
students to prepare a lot before to
practice brain is like any other muscle
the more you practice it the better gets
so when you have a large pool of
candidates and only small number of
spaces usually have drill exams because
what they're showing is where the
candidate is serious enough whether
they're able to practice in how they
perform under time limited pressured
environment
additions they're not necessarily
prediction whether that candidate will
then do very well in the next step of
Education so right now I have you know
two students who from India's top
technology when from deadly other from
Madras so right now they are here and
carrying out research on applying AI
artificial agent and deep learning
techniques for medical application so
this work they are able to do within you
know short span of time
the demonstrate their skills and ability
[Music]
maybe a train is moving at this velocity
had this speed we need to consider is it
really possible is it feasible and then
there are questions about experience
have I actually seen a wire with young's
modulus of this zipper is it really
possible so those type of questions are
actually come from experience so we
actually have to try out various
experiments in lab you have to know that
what exactly have the range is
practicality that exist in science to
mark so maybe half mark can change your
rang bitrate amount it's possible I
getting - remarks can decrease your rang
by 200 or 400 so you need to be very
careful about how to attend which
coefficient to attempt and we need to be
very sure about a tempting than question
may be yeah for other students that are
preparing well je I feel being
open-minded is what would really help
right now all those that are thinking of
maybe starting in class 10 or 9 I feel
that they need to be open-minded they
need to be considerate that yes
experience in life's are very important
apart from studies I feel that those
experience can really help not only in
je but also otherwise and yeah enjoying
life is very important with study one of
my thing would be don't be scared of the
exam hall examination hall so I have
experienced that in je mean that's
that's not good
so we open be free whatever you're
studying just protect a thing and yeah
all the best always been insane yes so
when I look through it there was a lot
of the questions that they are based
very much on this sort of principle of
memorization and recitation which i
think is just an extraordinarily bad
educational tool because of assumes that
everyone has the exact same capabilities
in that area and as someone who never
had a great memory for these things and
had to work extra hard and then became a
professional physicist for over a decade
you realize very quickly that those
particular skills don't help you much at
all once you're actually working as a
scientist because you know scientists
you know get to the point where the
material they're working with us so
complicated you just don't remember no
one could remember it so that that skill
of memorization and recitation is not
not as helpful as people might think in
science you know you tend to not be
successful every day of your working
career in fact quite the opposite you
tend to you know not get anywhere for
quite a while I mean you'll have one
lucky day where something will occur and
your training will allow you to see that
and identify it as being special and
that's what makes a good scientist but
for the other 360 odd days of the year
you'll you'll have a you know pretty
rough time and those sorts of skills
those sorts of resilience skills and
understanding how science and
engineering work you know the process of
falsification is not something that is
tested at all in these sorts of
examinations and it's unfortunate
because you want people with those
skills more than you want people with
schools with memorized memorization
capabilities when I looked at the JW
Matic advanced maths exams it led me to
recall an interesting article by the
great British mathematician and gh Hardy
Indian viewers of this blog will perhaps
be well equated with Hardy who was it
was generally regarded as responsible
for bringing the great Indian math
Ramanujan to the attention of the world
then so Indian viewers should have some
affection for Hardy you have to
understand that when Hardy was a young
man and through the early stages of his
career mathematical education in the
United Kingdom was governed by the
mathematical Tripos examination for
Cambridge undergraduates this was a
highly competitive examination an
examination of great difficulty in the
sense that it required a large amount of
preparation and training paying for
professional coaching and so on like
that
and on the basis of your try post result
this could lead to academic
possibilities but also to to high
positions in the British civil service
in the Cologne and the Colonial Office
and things like that in fact it was
viewed generically as some kind of way
of detecting deep intellectual
superiority and ranking people and Hardy
didn't have much time for that Hardy was
actually quite a fan of examinations and
quite a fan of lecturing as I am and
this is unfashionable these days what he
was not comfortable with was the tripods
particularly in the in the the first
version in which he encountered in order
for the exam to work the way it did a
kind of culture had built up in terms of
the setting of the questions the kinds
of questions and so on like that and
most of these had very little to do with
mathematics that was either practically
used or intellectually interesting or
anything recent in mathematics it was
basically playing certain games the
examiners would try and set slightly
sneaky questions on certain topics and
students would hope to have practiced
lots of questions of a vaguely similar
type in the hope that they could get
through this and hardly saw this as
actually warping mathematical education
in the United Kingdom so hard his
argument was examinations of the tripod
style are not a very good way to rank
people intellectually and therefore
perhaps one might consider doing things
differently it would be drawing a
longbow to claim that the J EE advanced
examination suffers from the defects of
the
rooibos nonetheless there are elements
of analogy there particularly the issue
of expensive coaching and the diversion
of students away from studying subjects
and developing their abilities and
instead teaching them to do certain
kinds of questions at great speed which
is not actually something of great use
are either in the practical applications
of mathematics in the real world
or in academic mathematics scientific
research or scholarship
[Music]